il faut bien vérifier dans les fonds et
die sait si la France distribue des
fonds notamment pour le peuple
palestinien mais souvent il y a la
corruption et il faudrait s'assurer que
ces fonds ne vont pas dans la poche des
terroristes donc ce que j'attends aussi
de la France c'est pas seulement des
actes politique de communication ce que
j'attends c'est une vraie action W il
nous reste 30 secondes pour évoquer ces
craintes de voir une importation du
conflit qui se qui touche le Proche
Orient en France on a vu Gérald Darmanin
et Gabriel hatal ce se montré très ferme
il parle d'une cinquantaine de faits
antisémites depuis samedi qu'est-ce que
vous avez comme retour vous dans les
département est-ce que il y a cette
crainte qui est forte aujourd'hui la
crainte elle existe elle s'est exprimée
par la voix du ministre de l'Intérieur
ce weekend puisque dès ce weekend
aussitôt il a réagi pour indiquer que
les les lieux notamment les synagogues
et cetera bénéficieraient d'une
protection lieux voilà des écoles syn C
poli gendarmob exactement c'est c'est
très important ce qui veut bien dire
qu'il y a un problème quand même ce qui
veut bien dire que on est face à un
phénomène où il y a une identification
non pas au drapeau français de gens qui
sont pour autant français mais à
d'autres drapeaux et parfois même à ces
actes terroristes et souvenez-vous
d'ailleurs dans la minute de silence que
après les attentats en 2015 certains
professeurs avaient demandé dans
certaines écoles cette minute n'avait
pas pu être observé bien merci merci
Bruno retaillot président du groupe alr
au Sénat pour cette réaction en direct
au micro de Public Sénat merci merci
merci beaucoup Quentin et place au
débrief de ces question au gouvernement
avec sur ce plateau la sénatrice Union
centriste de l'Orne Nathalie Goulet
bonjour également sur ce plateau le
sénateur communiste de Paris Yanne
brossa bonjour nouvellement élu bonjour
et bienvenue on entend Bruno rotaillot
qui parle d'une proposition de
résolution qu'il compte soumettre aussi
à différents groupes Nathalie Goulet
votre réaction et souhaitez-vous vous
joindre à et bien cette proposition de
résolution du président du groupe LR
écoutez je je je suis pas comme
SaintThomas je crois que ce que je vois
et pour l'instant la résolution je l'ai
pas vu mais il y a pas de raol il y a
pas de raison qu'on si elle ce si pas si
elle correspond à ce que nous pensons
sur le sujet pas de pas de raison de de
vous y opposer est-ce que c'est la même
chose du côté du groupe communiste Yann
brossa bon vous dites difficile de
parler de quelque chose don qu'on a pas
encore vu mais le fond en l'occurrence
cette proposition de résolution ne nous
a pas été soumise donc il est par
conséquent un peu compliqué pour moi de
de me prononcer dessus en revanche
Cécile kckierman notre présidente de
groupe présidente du groupe CRCE au
Sénat a demandé qu'un débat puisse être
organisé sur ce qui s'est passé et sur
la situation au proche- Orient parce
que- parce que je pense qu'il est
effectivement utile que nous puissions
échanger sur cette situation et sur le
rôle que la diplomatie française doit
jouer pour qu'on retrouve dans cette
région du monde un chemin de paix vous
inquiétez de la tournure que prend
aujourd'hui le débat aussi en France
cela faisait partie également de de ce
que vous disiez à l'intérieur du
communiqué du groupe communiste je
trouve parfaitement légitime qu'on ait
l'expression d'une émotion et d'une
solidarité vis-à-vis des victimes de ces
actes terroristes c'est parfaitement
naturel et le Sénat est tout à fait dans
son rôle lorsqu'il le fait et c'est ce
qui a été fait cet après-midi simplement
je pense qu'il y a une deuxième question
qui doit se poser maintenant c'est
comment on retrouve un chemin de paix
comment la France permet que dans cette
région du monde on puisse envisager une
solution de paix parce que le risque
c'est un embrasement de l'ensemble du
Proche Orient et donc c'est la question
que nous que nous souhaitons évoquer
Nathalie Goulet est-ce que c'est déjà le
moment de pouvoir parler de processus de
paix quand on voit effectivement
l'embrasement qui est en train de gagner
et bien l'ensemble du Moyen-Orient et et
notamment et bien le blocus de Gaza fait
par Israël aujourd'hui en réponse à cet
attentat moi jeis un tout petit peu plus
pragmatique on a eu une question une
séance de question d'actualité on a eu
assez peu de réponses n'est-ce pas bon
je pense notamment à la question de HERV
Marseille sur le financement du
terrorisme vous savez que c'est un de
mes dadas euh nous avons lors sur le
rôle de du Qatar le rôleatar le rôle de
l'Iran les financements européens qui ne
sont pas contrôlés les financements
d'association qui ne sont pas contrôlés
et chaque année au moment du projet de
loi de finances je dépose des
amendements avec mon groupe pour plus de
contrôle chaque année on nous explique
que tout va bien j'espère qu'aujourd'hui
de façon extrêmement pragmatique et
parce que ces attaques terroristes ont
été organisé financé ces gens ont été
entraînés c'est pas arrivé comme ça par
hasard en un clin d'œil vous voyez que
tout ça a fait l'objet d'une d'une
terrible organisation et aussi d'un
financement mortifère vous appelez à la
suspension de ces aides on a vu qu'il y
avait tout un débat européen avec des
désaccords aujourd'hui ah non non mais
attendez si on supprime les aides
européennes aujourd'hui à Gaza on fait
le jeu du Hamas les gens qui veulent
supprimer les aides n'ont rien compris
au problème je parle pas de ça je parle
du contrôle des aides je parle pas de
leur suppression pas de suspension mais
du contrôle bien sûr et on a et on a
aussi une on a aussi un problème avec
avec le Qatar avec l'Iran avec des
associations tout à fait nationales
européennes qui ont financer des
mouvements terroristes qui se retrouvent
là-bas donc là c'est pas une résolution
qu'il faut c'est appliquer des
dispositifs ou en prendre de nouveau
allez on continue les réactions salle
des conférences on a entendu les
présidents de groupe on va écouter
Patrick canner le président du groupe
socialiste au micro de Quentin bonjour
Patrick canner merci de nous rejoindre
ici en direct sur l'e de public sén on
voit cette proposition d'une résolution
voulue par Bruno r est-ce que les
socialiste pourrait joindre leur
signature à cette résolution brunotillot
en sa qualité de président du premier
groupe a pris déjà ce type d'initiative
sur l'Ukraine sur aussi le Hard donc le
Haab auprès de l'Arménie voilà donc on n
est pas du tout opposé il faut bien sûr
voir son C mais ce qui est très
important c'est de montrer que sur des
sujets qui peuvent être très consensuels
en droit international et bien oui les
socialistes sont prêts à signer en
fonction bien bien sûr de son contenu
est-ce que dans cette résolution il
pourrait être question de de ces fameux
crimes contre l'humanité que géréral
lcher souhaite qualifier comme tel il
appelle l'exécutif à utiliser ces mots
il appelle l'exécutif à dire à nos
partenaires européens de reprendre cette
expression vous êtes d'accord avec C oui
il faut nommer les choses vous savez la
notion de crime contre l'humanité relève
du droit international c'est extrêmement
précis ce que nous avons vécu assister
depuis le 7 octobre montre que voilà ce
n'est pas une une armée régulière qui a
commis ces ces actes monstrueux
insoutenables c'est bien une bande de
terroristes qui voulait permettez-moi
l'expression tu es du Juif c'était bien
cela dont il était question
malheureusement pendant ce ce weekend
face à ce constat sans appel que vous
évoquez que dire de ce malaise à gauche
autour du fait de nommer le Hamas comme
un un un groupe terroriste vous avez
parlé d'indignité lors de cette séance
vous visez très clairement les les
insoumis ils ont commis une indignité
je je ne vise pas les insignés en tant
que parti je vise certains leaders et
pas tous d'ailleurs monsieur Ruffin a eu
une position différente courageuse et un
autre député nous le savons de Paris je
considère que effectivement à force de
tourner autour du pot peut-être pour des
raisons électorales mais ça c'est à l'
fi de de l'évoquer et bien ils sont en
train de se couper de ce que devrait
être la gauche de responsabilité vous
connaissez mes critiques sur laanup
sur LFI et bien j'ai le sentiment
malheureusement que j'avais raison et
depuis de nombreux mois donc que LFI
fasse son introspection pour faire
bouger les lignes justement on voit le
chef de votre partie le premier
secrétaire Olivier fort qui hésite à
quitter officiellement laanupe on a vu
dans le monde que ça aurait pu être dès
hier que ça a été annoncé on voit que ça
a une hésitation faut-il que votre chef
de fil le disent clairement le PS
n'appartient plus à la nuupe jusqu'à
nouvel ordre vous savez Olivier fort est
à la tête d'un parti démocratique
qui prend ses décisions de manière
collective un bureau national hier il
aurait pu le proposer des il y a un
bureau national hier mais nous avons un
conseil national samedi donc c'estàd le
Parlement du PS et une résolution en ce
sens sera portée discutée nous verrons
bien si elle obtient la majorité et donc
vous vous soutiendrez samedi le fait de
sortir de l' nuup moi je considère que
il y aura eu un avant et un après 7
octobre au sein de la gauche française
mais malheureusement nos affaires
politiciennes sont tellement peu de
choses par rapport au malheur que vit
aujourd'hui bien sûr merci Patrick
canner pour cette réaction au micro de
public c'est merci merci beaucoup
Quentin nos affaires politiciennes n'ont
pas grand chos à faire dans cette
situation mais on voit la nup qui est en
train de se désagréger Yanne brossa
aujourd'hui face à la position de la
France insoumise qui pour l'instant ne
refuse de parler du Hamas comme d'une
organisation terroriste d'attaque
terroriste après ce qui s'est passé
samedi en tout cas en ce qui nous
concerne nous je parle de de de notre
groupe de de de ma sensibilité politique
Fabien Roussel a exprimé des choses
extrêmement claires nous avons dénoncé
ces actes qui sont des actes terroristes
et et qui nécessite je crois une
condamnation unanime après les autres
formations politiques de laanup peuvent
avoir des propos différents mais pour ce
qui nous concerne ce que nous avons dit
et je crois extrêmement clair et ne
souffre d'aucune espèce d'ambiguïé je
trouve eff est-ce que vous avez besoin
de rompre avec Al fi en ce moment vous
dites c'est pas le moment mais
honnêtement on a une situation au Proche
Orient qui est absolument
et on va commencer à compter les points
à l'intérieur de notre coalition tout ça
ne me paraît pas très digne et je pense
que dans les moments dramatiqu comme
ceux que nous vivons en ce moment on a
besoin de dignité et je trouve
d'ailleurs que notre séance de de
question au gouvernement au Sénat a
témoigné d'une forme de dignité et si
nous pouvions continuer sur cette lignée
là je pense que nous en sortirions
grandi alors vous parlez de cette séance
de question au gouvernement parmi les
temps fors on retient aussi
l'intervention de Roger kucci qui est
président du groupe d'amitié
franceisraël et on écoute ce qu'il a dit
tout à l'heure en
séance nous sommes là pour vous dire
qu'il faut utiliser les mots crime
contre l'humanité c'est la réalité ce
mot cette expression utilisezla
faites-la utiliser par l'Europe
franchement vu ce qui s'est passé crime
contre l'humanité c'est bien le minimum
la légitime défense de l'État d'Israël
c'est un droit permanent quand vous
recevez des milliers de de missile et
que vous assistez à ce qui s'est passé
dans les kibut légitime défense c'est le
minimum et faites en sorte madame la
Première ministre que celles et ceux qui
dans la République trahissent les
valeurs de la République trahissent les
valeurs de la nation en ne soutenant pas
l'état d'Israël et en faisant l'apologie
du terrorisme faites en sorte qu'il soit
sévèrement puni plusieurs choses dans
cette intervention mais tout d'abord sur
ce terme de crime contre l'humanité on a
aussi entendu l'ambassadeur d'Israël
reprendre ce terme le président du Sénat
parler de crime contre l'humanité est-ce
que vous adhérez à cette expression
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est ce qui
qualifie ce qui s'est passé samedi pour
vous natthalie Goulet a priori après les
images et et ce qu'on a déjà entendu et
les témoignages ça ça s'y apparente
puisque c'est le plus grand massacre de
juifs depuis la Choa donc il y a bien là
une volonté d'élimination physique d'une
population civile je pense qu'on y est
très très près moi je voudrais d'abord
revenir sur ce qu'a dit notre collègue
brossa c'est la dignité de cette séance
la dignité des hommages la dignité de
chacun d'entre nous dans nos à nos à nos
places et sur nos bancs et sur les
différents bancs du Sénat je pense que
c'était l'honneur du Sénat cette
question et et cette séance
d'aujourd'hui on a entendu aussi
l'intervention de Roger carucci qui
parle aussi de de son inquiétude sur et
bien
des une allusion à la France